même si la billetterie n'est pas encore
ouverte l édition 2020 du festival rock
en seine aura encore bien lieu à la fin
du mois d'août et pour la quatrième
année la région ile-de-france va
permettre à des lycéens de monter sur
scène et des tremplins vont avoir lieu
dans tous les départements dont les
yvelines c'est la mjc les terrasses à
conflans sainte honorine qui a été
choisie pour accueillir les sélections
qui cherchait une structure qui
accompagne déjà des groupes qui
travaillent avec les jeunes et donc
c'est vraiment notre notre mission en
fait à l'année s'est adressé avant tout
aux lycéens et aux jeunes de moins de 21
ans
il faut qu est à peu près 50% à l'ère du
groupe qui sont encore lycéen l'année
dernière le tremplin des lycéens
s'étaient déroulés à l' usine à chapeaux
à rambouillet pour cette édition à la
finale aura lieu le 17 mai à l'occasion
du festival bonne machine
les lauréats bénéficieront d'un
accompagnement on évaluera avec le
groupe qu'elles sont vraiment leurs
besoins de ceux ci c'est plus seuls des
besoins scénic ou plus des besoins
techniques
voilà donc on fera vraiment un
comportement là dessus pour qu'il soit
dans les meilleures dispositions pour
pour jouer sur scène lors du festival
rock en seine
chaque groupe devra présenter au minimum
deux compositions originales
les inscriptions sont ouvertes jusqu'au
4 avril